mcdonald's people are not happy with
them and their
score I the American Customer Service
index is
balling let's take a look so this is a
favorability score for pretty big chain
restaurants fast food restaurant we do a
budget passed would stop here
people people are always a very
passionate about it so
papillons doing pretty well they got a
82 at a hundred which is the
been moved from last year people like
them in 2013 they like I'm in 2014
Pizza Hut number too so people seem to
really like
no generic chain heated is that where
you guys fauna year old
at all from the midwest I didn't know if
there was anything more exotic than a
pizza hut but
that right there I don't know how you
could diamond
right so this is like new york obviously
you're not gonna go to Pizza Hut or
dominos or Papa Johns
young got real it but I let that go back
to start their again then Little Caesars
the Dominos Pizza the first four people
are very satisfied
which she Peter I but then okay so
they're on the bottom
are the last four Burger King Dunkin
Donuts KFC
talk about McDonagh again defied their
so mcdonald's really kinda struggling
and I was but I was watching something
in
you know that people have said that
their numbers their their take on right
now is dropping
a little bit companies is partly just
people I could beat up
on the thing that they secretly love
like everyone talks shit about Walmart
and everyone shops there
you know although I actually I went
there to get a big screen TV in the
customer service was so bad actually
brought the TV up
carry the TV myself brought it to the
razor and was taking so long and they're
being so unpleasant I just left it there
the jury finds you return the sports
coat despite
for AoE
I didn't nearly burst but yeah I really
do think that summer what's going on
here like without hasn't changed that
much
there's no reason you know I'll yeah all
alive
it would all the lies in the world I'll
be by mcdonald's because is both but
without me I'll
got and then you go and you buy the
entire dollar menu
new roomier let me ask McDonald you can
say that like
be at this is in this day and age for
everyone be organic and natural and
gluten-free an XY and z.
you can't say like how do you feel after
you've done that in your room
just portal dollar and forget that yeah
I question spiral I could change my
earlier too
we should all go out on the town maybe
you could too frankly I don't you
what who is this like secret hate like
you ok well I haven't got the email
absolutely disagree for one reason yeah
because I don't know if it was two days
ago or yesterday
the the me abominable horrible thing
that happened to that little girl at KFC
when
she was mauled by a dog yeah and she was
scarred and the family took credit if
the
asked her to leave a little girl because
is making the other customers I'm
comfortable
if that's what customer service is the
fast food bahcall about the and that is
what I has rejected they're not already
quite served to fall
by the way I'm pretty sure kFC has now
helped her pay for medical bills
show understand the corporate wasn't
there there's just some dude
drug whatever I don't hurt the
thousand-dollar for
medical bills or million that a lawsuit
yeah I am
you don't blame the founder of on
right-wing occur or that cracking
but I i do understand you know if they
probably wouldn't have wanted their
employees that treat another person like
that
but if that's the culture your breeding
then I don't feel sorry for you
and there is a lot of that because here
even in LA now that I wanna make
everything that early but if you were to
go to In N Out
in a smile there friendly I mean Erica
point-of-service look me in the eye
they are happy to be there but now they
don't give a flying fuck about you and I
get to take their pay and everything is
different business model at
but a good but OK KFC because the other
two so at the bottom
were KFC and Taco Bell Taco Bell I think
has the reverse thing a mic is it cool
to like Taco Bell
you it's for breathing for
500 they got the jury does
aka the kids love it there at some Taco
Bell playing
that the commercial for the old people
in every bank in love so I think they
get the reversing somehow it's cool to
say
that you like Taco Bell not cool to say
you like made out to my and I think I'm
well
completely is the same thing as movie
idiocracy they may reach about
you can take the remaining nine
ingredients and shuffle the deck in a
different way
get all the product to get people
excited they're geniuses were morons but
their genes that by the way in the movie
idiocracy which is such an underrated
Matt
really so spectacular the one fast food
restaurant that survives the future
is Carl's junior which didn't which is
horrible which is horrible that didn't
even make a
the brass people like you good players
not on the list that cover the
always like that happen question what
about the gay bareback gay thing
up I okay but
people though fight
you know what we had Paris area on a
couple months ago and he made the same
are you and I love their idea I want gay
people like what
you know you can't wait you can't win
over him I anyway the point is made out
with just not that great
at you probably be happier elsewhere